mais ça fait quand même et on a un
témoignage comme ça de quelqu'un qui est
sur le terrain et qui connaît la
magistrature ça fait quand même un petit
peu peur on va revenir sur votre livre
dans un instant parce que ça rejoint un
petit peu ça rejoint on va avoir besoin
de vous nous éclairer sur la sphère qu'a
vécu le drame qui avec magali berda sida
il ya un peu plus de dix jours dans la
nuit du 9 au 10 octobre dernier karine
votre belle soeur et son compagnon ont
été sauvagement assassinés dans leur
appartement près de marseille lors de
corps ont été retrouvés par une des
filles de la victime il gisait nu dans
une mare de sang une scène d'horreur
vécues par votre belle famille le
meurtrier présumé qui serait donc le
voisin et est incarcéré
selon les premiers témoignages l'homme
serait un déséquilibré
histoire de fou parce que tout le monde
en a parlé de cette affaire i
zisis il avait trois enfants julie kim
et mélissa cessa de 12 ans 17 ans et 24
ans des trois fils n'avait pas de
nouvelles de leur maman et de leur beau
père depuis la veille au soir elle est
inquiète parce qu'elle normalement ils
répondent tout le temps et les leçons il
y avait il y avait un drame
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait au
départ elles n'ont pas de nouvelles de
leur maman et les filles ont cherché à
joindre la famille enfin un joint de
leur part leur mère et leur beau pays
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais elles ont
cherché à joindre ma belle-soeur et et
pas de nouvelles donc à sont allés sur
place et julie a trouvé sa mère et ils
sont on a mis par terre et avec un drap
sur reposée et une scène assez compliqué
et
et ses deux petites soeurs attendait sur
sur le parking donc entendu crier donc
les petites sont lentes et également et
julie a crié et le voisin aujourd'hui
julie elle a 24 ans publié la 24 la plus
grande et je les embrasse parce qu'elle
nous regarde là et et le voisin est
sorti les sorties en plus donc la
présence et bras votre mari l'avait il
n'avait pas de nouvelles de sa soeur non
plus d'avis il a essayé de la paix non
parce que c'était un dimanche en fait
est que pour être honnête ça me plait
pas afin d'assurer un voilà donc mais
elles nous ont appelés de la balle est
petit alors vers 18 heures contre la
fille aînée donc julie monte à
l'appartement de fred se trouve ça va
bon puisque c'est une beau père et c'est
là que donc elle découvre l'horreur
comment elle peut vous décrire ça
qu'elle découvre donc c'est ça sa mère
son beau père gisant dans une mare de
son avec un drap sur eux
elle est traumatisée elle est très
perturbé les deux petites aussi elles
sont dans un état
sont fortes mais qu'il faut suivre quoi
maintenant il faut les aider il faut les
accompagner est long et sont restés que
la police qu'à 22h sur ce parking et
après ils ont été emmenés au
commissariat les deux grandes îles sont
restés au commissariat une heure du
matin parler de leur maman et à répondre
aux questions donc c'était assez
insoutenable pour actes de torture s'est
mise à hurler lorsqu'elle a découvert la
scène hélas le voisin qui aujourd'hui le
meurtrier présumé sort et la provence et
brassac et donc c'est le voisin qui est
le meurtrier présumé qui sort en
entendant les cris en fait elle était
sur lui comme si elle a vu quelqu'un que
sortir dans qu'elle a cherchés venait de
quoi donc ea s'est jeté sur lui et l'a
prise dans ses bras et après il est
rentré dans son appartement à lui en
disant qu'ils pouvaient pas voir il
faisait comme s'il avait peur qu'il
était je peux pas regarder ça je peux
pas voir ça et il est rentré dans son
appartement et du coup c'est les autres
voisins qui sont venus l'aider et la
police est arrivée donc il n'a pas voulu
voir la scène non c'est histoire
complètement folle et c'est fou et s'il
faut qu'elle se jette dans les bras de
la pauvre qui se jette dans les bras de
meurtrier présumé de sa sa maman
et
je te fuit
les autres petit filet 2 les deux plus
jeunes qui ont 12 ans et 17 ans elles
ont vu cette semaine également elles
sont montées kim s'est jetée par terre
donc un code 17 ans c'est ça et et
mélissa la petite je pense qu'ils l'ont
rattrapé et ils les ont laissées sur le
parking après avec la police ils ont été
les prises d'empreintes et c'est parce
que forcément il y avait des empreintes
à faire tout de suite ils les ont
interrogés elles sont restés très
longtemps sur ce parking est et après
emmené au commissariat on a repris
l'avion tout de suite parce qu'elles
nous ont appelés devant le corps de
karine et donc on a requis un avion on a
eu la chance d'avoir un avion
immédiatement et de pouvoir les
rejoindre mais elles étaient bloqués au
commissariat alors julie appelle la
police forcément qui arrive à 18h45
c'est là qu'il ya le premier problème
les forces de l'ordre oblige les filles
à rester sur le parking de la résidence
jusqu'à 22h heure d'arrivée de la police
judiciaire
il fallait attendre la police judiciaire
donc les filles elles devaient rester
sur le parking sachant que leur maman
était
morte au dessus dans l'appartement ils
doivent attendre jusqu'à 22 heures sur
le parking de la résidence
comment ils ont vécu ça
c'était dur et je pense que ça amplifie
le traumatisme elle elle avait envie de
nous rejoindre elle avait envie d'être
avec nous à les avoir obligés à rester
c'est normal dans la procédure ça c'est
que c'est quand la police a dit qu'il
fallait répondre aux questions et qu'il
fallait prendre les empreintes et
attendre la police judiciaire et après
elles ont été emmenées au commissariat
et julie et leur a demandé de rentrer
leur a dit s'il vous plaît je veux
rentrer avec ma famille parce que
je veux je rentrais quoi ça y est j'ai
répondu à des questions etc ils ont dit
non c'est pas possible il faut que tu
viennes il faut venir vous êtes obligés
de venir donc elles ont elles sont
restés là bas jusqu'à une heure du matin
et sans on va me dire y'a pas
psychologue en permanence c'est vrai
mais peut-être qu'il en faudrait
peut-être qu'il faudrait penser aux
victimes parce que ben c'est des gamines
sont des enfants et qu'elles sont
restées jusqu'à une heure du matin à
répondre à des questions sur leur mère à
savoir qui était leur mère en quelle
année aller mais en quelle année a
divorcé en quelle année sociale et
c'est pour les besoins de l'enquêté
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué mais
est-ce qu'on peut pas attendre un peu le
lendemain peut-être que c'est pas mais
on n'est pas tenue mais enfin il ya un
problème de preuve à préserver mais bon
le penser s'agissant de l'audition d'un
ancien des jeunes mineurs on aurait pu
attendre le lendemain ça joue bien ou la
corde il n'a rien eu à peu près six mois
je veux pas incriminer la police parce
que je pense que la police c'est
vraiment extrêmement bien qu'on
travaille donc le but c'est vraiment pas
je pense que le système va pas je pense
qu'il ya un vrai problème dans le
système et que ça vient d'eux au dessus
les officiers de police par la police
judiciaire qui l'a reçu moi j'ai été
reçu le lendemain avec mon conjoint est
avec son frère également et ont vraiment
été très gentils et c'est important pour
moi de le dire quand même que je t'ai
mise au courant du drame bah parce que
qui mêle à nous appeler voilà la moyenne
elle nous a appelés en nous disant vite
mais comment il est au téléphone ce que
quand on est du relais à wind allure les
maps les mois et stéphane est à côté de
moi donc c'était marie mais c'est très
compliqué et à hurler il ya eu ma mère
est morte et voilà et et
balade en ce moment là on sait pas et
on sait pas ce qui se passe lors au
début il paraît que vous dites que c'est
le compagnon de de karine on pensait ça
donc le nouveau le beau-père donc des
trois enfants qui avaient reculé qu'à
tuer votre belle soeur
et tu appelles la police au lendemain tu
tentes d'avoir des informations et c'est
là que tu reprends que ce n'est pas du
tout frais donc le compagnon de karine
qui l'a tuée mais c'est en fait un
double homicide puisque lui aussi il est
mort tu sais pas au départ qu'il était
qu'il est et qu'il avait été tué lui
aussi on savait si on savait qu'il était
décédé parce qu'elle les abus sexuels il
avait tué on s'est dit il ya peut-être
eu un drame entre les deux il peut être
tué après décider
j'entends rester ensemble ça faisait
quelques années way et en fait non il
disputait souvent donc on s'est dit
peut-être qu'il ya eu on sait pas en
fait qu on cherche des réponses pense
que le pire dans tout ça c'est vraiment
d'avoir des réponses donc ça nous
conforte de trouver des réponses dont
consommer des trucs dans la tête parce
que ça nous aide en fait ça aide la
famille et puis c'était pas vrai et la
police m'a dit non c'est un double
homicide mais on a su que le lendemain
après midi alors parce que j'ai appelé
qu'est-ce que tu te dis à ce moment là
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui sont
dit peut-être que c'est un règlement de
compte c'est ce qu'on avait entendu au
tout début c'est les gens se sont
imaginés plein de choses tu te dis quoi
toi départ au départ quand on lit ce qui
se dit dans la presse parce qu'on n'a
aucune information de la police mais
vraiment aucune c'est normal aussi pour
l' enquête c'est normal on était en état
de flagrant si l'on nous ont expliqué
cette notion là donc tu découvres tout
dans la presse et que je suis l'avancé
des avancées de l'enquète dans la presse
tout est là on voit des trucs dans la
presse en disant de la drogue des faux
papiers des histoires pas possible on
s'est dit mais qu'est ce qu'un et on
tombe des nues parce que ma belle-soeur
c'était une femme normale fin semble pas
ça faisait quoi dans la vie tabellion
elle travaillait était commercial elle
faisait peur à bout l'ol subvenait aux
besoins de ses enfants et de ses parents
six habitaient tous ensemble avec ses
parents aussi et
on se met des doutes même en fait c'est
à dire qu'on arrive même nous à se dire
mais est ce qu'il ya des choses qu'on
savait pas on a loupé c'était pas un
après a commencé à s'en vouloir c'est
peut-être j'ai pas été là pour eux son
frère en a pas voilà et on les a
peut-être pas assez aidés on a peut-être
faute et
on passe par plein d'état compliqué
quand on sait pas
alors tu appelles la police à plusieurs
reprises et non pas pis tu te dise
savent pas ils enquêtent ils nous disent
qu'ils ne peuvent absolument rien nous
dire jusqu'à ce que mon nom sort dans la
presse le lendemain encore il pareil
peur que oui les organes où le meurtrier
présumé il s'en prennent à toi oui parce
que sur le moment je me suis retrouvé
avec je ne sais pas combien d'articles
avec mon nom et puis avec ces histoires
de drogue de trucs alors on dit non
seulement l'image de ma belle soeur et
son son son honneur a été bafouée
gratuitement parce qu en aucun cas il
était question du coût de drogue et de
papiers ni de rien du tout et en plus
bas fin ça mais on ne savait pas à ce
moment là et quand j'ai vu mon nom je me
suis dit mais si vraiment il y avait
quelque chose qu'on sait pas est ce que
maintenant peut-être ils vont voir qui
je suis du coup ils vont être parce que
pour pour avoir tué comme ça il faut
être fou enfin cesser complètement
hallucinant donc je j'ai eu peur donc
j'ai appelé la police ils à reading je
leur ai dit excusez moi mais qu'est ce
qui se passe faut nous dire parce que
moi j'ai peur j'ai aussi trois enfants
donc qu'est-ce que quoi mon ex mari m'a
appelé m'a dit qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est enfin ces
histoires et tout ça et même pour les la
sécurité des petits du coût de ses
filles à elle de ses parents enfin ils
nous ont dit écoutez on peux rien vous
dire alors c'est vrai que là tu vois
dans la presse des choses incroyables
que ta belle soeur et consommatrices de
drogue qu'elle est impliquée dans des
mariages blancs c'est ce qui tournait un
moment que c'est que cette histoire donc
là que tu vois ça c'est double si c'est
un drame c'est sale c'est très sale et à
c'est donc dans ton compagnon qui sont
frères c'est très sale pour nous on est
adulte mais pour ces enfants en fait ces
enfants moi c'est pour ça que hier quand
j'ai repris mes réseaux sociaux et j'ai
parlé sur mes réseaux la première chose
c'est est de laver les conneries excusez
moi du terme est lent délicatesse et la
pourriture de ce qui a pu être dit dans
la presse pour les petites nous on s'en
fout parce qu'en vrai voilà mais les
petites elles ont déjà la douleur
d'avoir perdu leur maman et est en plus
d'entendre des trucs pareils
je pense que la presse devrait attendre
des fois avant de sortir certaines
choses
les trois filles quand elles voient
salle de l ont dû réagir aussi dû se
dire mais qu'est ce qu'on va en chercher
on s'est dit ah ce qui c'est on appelle
on a loupé quelque chose
quand explique que la presse est plus
d'infos
que la famille dès que la famille des
victimes
bah c'est alors ce que j'ai trouvé
bizarre c'est que c'était totalement
assumée moi j'ai appelé plusieurs fois
vraiment et encore une fois vraiment
j'ai affaire à des gens très gentils les
policiers ont été extrêmement gentil est
vraiment très très professionnel mais
ils nous ont dit on peux rien vous dire
pour les raisons de l'enquêté ce que je
peux comprendre mais à un moment donné
le policier nous a dit le procureur va
s'exprimer ce soir ou demain matin
hélas quand il nous a dit ça on s'est
regardés avec mon conjoint et on s'est
dit ok mais il va dire quoi bah il
s'exprimera très bien mais et nous on va
là on attend bas vous regardez la presse
mais vous pouvez pas nous dire ça en
fait ça veut dire que si vous nous
refusez nous parler à nous pour l'
enquête on le comprend mais dans ces
cas-là parlait pas la presse non plus ou
alors dites-nous si allah nous au moins
qu'on soit pas sous le choc et qu'on
n'est pas des informations qui sortent
de la presse avant que ça sorte si vous
les communiquer à la presse pas de
problème mais au moins il faut aider les
familles des victimes s'est passé ils
nous mentent faire ça mais c'est le
système qui est mal fait encore une fois
je pense que c'est vraiment il ya un
vrai problème alors c'est énorme c'est
normal ça alors au niveau de l'enquêté
préliminaire puisque nous est au stade
de l enquête préliminaire vous n'avez
pas accès au dossier c'est selon le bon
vouloir de la police du procureur qui
est le maître de la procédure effet une
taxe si vous voulez avoir accès au
dossier il faut vous constituer partie
civile devant le juge fait ça a été fait
ça va un avocat halak s'est constitué
vous allez pouvoir faire des demandes et
vous aurez en tant que victime accès au
dossier au niveau 2 c'est ça qui est qui
qui qui va pas les enquêtes
préliminaires ça peut durer alors il ya
un projet de réforme là qui est soumis
actuellement au parlement qu elle qui
était déposée par notre garde des sceaux
le qui vise à limiter ces deux ans
maintenant ça peut durer comme intention
pas simple ça peut durer il n'y a pas de
délai le procureur mf qui peut faire
traîner les choses que son bon vouloir
il n'a pas à s'expliquer
il rassemble les preuves il me mène ses
investigations comme il le souhaite mais
tant que le juge qui ne peut pas se
saisir lui-même il fut un temps le juge
d'instruction qui était l'homme le plus
puissant de france pouvait se saisir
d'office moi quand j'étais en poste à
mayotte je les fais une fois pour tester
c'était encore possible
je la cite des témoins d'une infraction
commise par un automobiliste d'avoir
bouté embouti des voitures et j'avais
pris donc
une ordonnance en disant je me saisir
d'office le procureur a fait appel
et puis j'ai été dessaisie du dossier
parce que la cour a évoqué l' affaire
donc il faut bien comprendre que au
niveau de l'enquêté le procureur le chef
d'orchestre c'est lui qui mène la
procédure qui donc vous deviez attendre
voilà que le produit procureur parle
pour pouvoir avoir dans la presse au
revoir pour pouvoir avoir des infos
savait pas non plus alors là un moment
tu apprends encore une fois dans la
presse qu'un suspect a été interpellé
par le raid et qu'il s'agit en fait du
fameux voisin qui n'osaient pas venir
voir l'a16 au départ qui avait pris donc
une des filles
une des filles de la victime dans ses
bras enfin il s'était jeté dans ses bras
croyant que c'était une aide où et
quand tu apprends ça c'est fou parce
qu'on a tout entendu et là tu te dis
quoi te dit tu le connais c'est toi ce
moment où vous l'aviez déjà vu pas du
tout moi je me suis dit
vraiment dans des mots excusez moi
encore mais c'est du foutage de gueule
en fait
parce que tout ça pour ça c'est salir
l'image de quelqu'un salir son sa
mémoire faire du mal à ses enfants faire
du mal à ses parents parce que je pense
aussi à mes beaux-parents à toute la
famille bah pour qu'au final ce soit le
voisin et tant mieux que ce soit le
voisin parce que ça montre que ma belle
soeur elle était elle était la personne
que je connaissais mais vous n'y avez
détention et que son voisin vous en avez
déjà entendu par nous n'ont apparemment
il faisait des faisait des des histoires
enfin il était bizarre ce qui se dit
dans le voisinage c'est que c'était un
homme bizarre qui n'était pas mais il y
avait des tensions avec eux avec votre
de votre patrie ainsi culièrement mais
vous en avez parler votre votre conjoint
s'il n'a jamais entendu parler d'eux il
en voulait en fait ta belle soeur et à
son compagnon ne sais pas s'il en
voulait on sait pas on n'a pas de
détails de du dossier on sait pas
pourquoi il a fait ça on sait pas on
sait juste que c'est lui que c'est le
reste est parti le chercher qu'il était
étrange on voit de tout mais
alors on a des leçons seraient pris déjà
s'en serait déjà pris à des voisins il
ya deux semaines pour une place de
parking il est décrit par plusieurs
sources comme le site un fou qui sort la
nuit de son appartement et appellerait
les dieux avec une lampe torche comme
s'ils étaient possédés
après le meurtre avant son
interpellation par le raid l'homme
serait resté enfermé pendant plusieurs
jours ils n'avaient des repas bien ils
étaient blafard en revanche depuis un an
l'homme avait changé de comportement il
se serait peut-être liées à sa situation
amoureuse
et on dit voilà on dit tu sais
pas ce que
c'est
s'il faut parce que c'était un véritable
massacre donc il a été on a l'impression
que c'était une personne qui était
possédé et qui s'est dit je vais
commettre un drame qui s'était c'est fou
parce que la scène de crime elle et elle
est
vraiment fort bien sûr c'est que ils ont
ils ont été eux
ils sont pris plusieurs coups de couteau
froid c'est ça je crois qu'ils aient eu
la boîte crânienne et
crade et donc c'est incroyable c'est
vraiment une jolie c'est un déferlement
de violence donc tout le monde était
persuadé que c'était il y avait une
histoire mais je sais juste un voisin le
voisin qui était
complètement malade fou et qui sont
épris
ses voisins de palier est ce que vous
savez comment c'est passé ou dans les
enquêtes qui commence non là c'est ce
qu'on sait c'est qu'il ya des voisins
qui ont entendu des cris est
malheureusement qui n'ont pas appelé la
police et
mais on n'a pas encore les détails de
comment il est rentré parce que
justement ils sont portés parties
civiles
vendredi et qu' ils doivent attendre
d'être reçu par le juge d'instruction
pour pouvoir avoir accès au dossier par
avancer comme ça que ça fonctionne et
moi je me dis juste que ce qui est
ce qui est grave dans tout ça c'est que
moi on a pu les est là pour elle et on a
pu gérer on va être là pour elle et
parce que maintenant ben voilà on est on
est soudés on est on est ensemble et
qu'on les lâchera pas mais comment font
les gens qui n'ont pas peut-être les
mêmes moyens que nous pour avoir des
avocats parce que j'ai pris deux avocats
qui ont réussi à avoir des informations
etc mais comment font les gens en fait
je comprends pas et je trouve que c'est
à vomir le système est encore une fois
c'est pas la police mais il ya un vrai
problème et quand on le temps qu'on le
vit pas on peut pas le comprendre c'est
moi je voyais ça dans les films me
disais mais mais en vrai c'est horrible
quoi c'est vraiment horrible cette
situation
quand on le vit soi même c'est terrible
il n'ya pire traumatisme que le
traumatisme judiciaire c'est quelque
chose qui reste à vie il faut il faut
vraiment s'attacher à ça alors vous avez
des informations concernant la cette
personne ne nie pas mais on prétend
qu'il est valide il est fou c'est ça fou
pendant alors cette fois ci le raid
pourquoi s'il règle qui est allés
l'interpeller parce que le règle qui
valent interpellé c'est quand même c'est
quand même un signal leur ai dit qu'ils
y passent pas pour rien on apporte quoi
ils se déplacent comme improbable public
sérieux quoi qu'il ya des menaces très
très sérieuse donc je suppose qu'il a
bêtement motif de se déplacer et ensuite
il tombe sur un type qui était
apparemment tout ça c'est le sait le
juge enfin c'est ben je sais ce qu'il
dira ce qu'il fait peur à à gagner
maintenant ça c'est ramènera jamais ça
fait sa famille mais on se dit
on a peur que la folie puisse excuser
son geste au jeu de la justice c'est ça
voilà le gros problème
voilà exactement
on a peur qu'on a peur qu'ils soient
déclarées irresponsables pénalement
c'est possible c'est le grand débat
est-ce qu'on doit est-ce qu'on a une
société est ce qu'on est capable de
juger des fucile concerne le problème
c'est le problème d'investigation pour
le juge comment est-ce qu'on va
déterminer qu'il est fou alors quand on
est un maître en matière criminelle
comme ça il ya des enquêtes qui sont
obligatoires enquêtes médico
psychologique en enquêteur
psychiatriques on est obligé de faire
appel à des experts et ce sont les
écumeurs des fois les contrats experts
et les batailles d'experts pour
déterminer si le
si l'auteur si le meurtrier était en
possession de tous ses moyens aussi il
avait une altération ou une abolition de
son discernement
zito si demain on le retrouve dehors
parce que voilà la folie excuser son
geste
c'est simple rien s'il est fou il
prétendra à m'arrêter il ira directement
la cie d'occitan ces intégristes est
resté combien de temps il restera
combien de temps le temps qu'il faudra
qu'ils voudraient pas accepter ça moi
j'ai aujourd'hui je suis enfin c'est
j'ai avec mon travail une puissance sur
les réseaux sociaux j'ai fait une story
hier j'en ai parlé et j'ai vu l'impact
que ça use j'ai reçu d'aidé peut-être
vraiment des milliers de messages de
gens victimes mais deux choses comme ça
j'en ai reçu des tonnes et je peux vous
garantir que la force aujourd'hui tu vas
voir sur mes réseaux sociaux je la
mettrai toute ma vie dans ce combat là
vraiment c'est pas mal ou pas
développant poche magali vous êtes
traumatisés aujourd'hui je suis pas
traumatisé fut triste car c'est normal
oui je suis triste parce que je me dis
qu'on a loupé les choses parce que je me
dis que je profite pas si de sa famille
c'est triste samedi la peine comme ma
belle famille j'ai assez profité 2 et
votre conjoint et ça me plaît at one
pour magna stéphanie les il n'est pas
vraiment pas bien il est vraiment pas
bien on est plein de remords en plein de
trois romans parce que c'est comme ça
c'est la vie est juste je pourrais pas
que c'était qu'on le déclare un fou
c'est ce que c'est de toute manière pour
tuer quelqu'un il faut être givré mais
oui donc de toute manière il faut être
fou dos quand on tue c'est qu'on est
fous donc ça n'excuse pas il n'y a plus
rien qui peut excuser ça on a enlevé une
maman de trois petites filles ou alors
ils avaient de bons motifs pour le faire
mais dans ce cas là
on saura où alors il est fou il n'y a
pas d'alternative faut être fou pour
tuer le foot one bank de toute manière
on y travaille où il est fou donc il
faut qu'il soit jugé donc je ne ne je ne
lâcherai rien là dessus et on
accompagnera mes nièces et
et mes beaux-parents et on ira jusqu'au
bout de ce combat là s'il s'avère que on
en arrive à ça mais la question vous
soulevez est très important s'est il
faut réfléchir à la place que doit
occuper la justice dans notre société
pour moi d'un morceau première mission
c'est de réguler des tensions sociales
cette mission d'apaisement de
soulagement quand on s'adresse à un juge
c'est qu'on est en grande souffrance
comme vous et vous espérez qu'un moment
par sa décision il va nous apporter un
soulagement une panne alors une
explication
malheureusement je veux bien faut pas
trop arriver parce que les juges ont des
petits moyens et je veux dire un
soulagement et c'est ça qu'il faut
remettre au coeur du débat de la
révolution ce moment ça c'est que les
trois enfants n'ont pas de suivi
psychologique
un coup de chine elles ont reçu un seul
coup tu es 2 2 qu'ils ont d'un service
d'une cellule psychologique le lendemain
bonjour c'est la cellule psychologique
mélissa qui a 12 ans elle et elle est où
la actuellement l'aller chez son grand
père et elle arrive chez moi demain donc
c'est vous qui allez là
l'instant est là ils vont monter là à
paris et on va essayer de sortir un
petit peu déjà de ceux de cet
environnement parce que trop de
souvenirs enfin trop de je pense qu'il
faisait une hache et un peu
psychologiquement ça arrive à elle
arrive à s'exprimer non elle est donc l
état parce que ce type de douleur
elle est dans le déni ah oui
qu'est ce que vous lui avez dit qui lui
a expliqué ce qui s'était passé tous ils
ont du coffre puisque c'est quoi les
mots qu'il avait employés
des des mots gentils après
malheureusement on est comme on peut
expliquer ça on peut pas l'expliquer
jeune fille de 12 ans séparent ont été
enfin sa maman été massacrés par le
voisin comment vous trouvez des mots que
lui ai dit quoi
on lui dit rien lui dit qu'on l'ait mais
qu' on est là on peut rien médias et
puis elle a vu des choses sur les
réseaux puis ses copines les enfin c'est
à dire ah ça c'est injuste on est on est
ensemble vos bons coins où ils vont mal
c'est normal ils ont perdu leur fille
comme ce mal et ma belle mère me disait
c'est pas le c'est pas le bon ordre la
veille elle lui a dit à tout et si tu es
un peu disputées pour raconter cette
anecdote et lui avait dit toi tu as
toute la vie devant toi profite et au
final est bien la vie à inverser les
choses donc c'est dur à réaliser pour
eux et
c'est les clients puissent habiter
ensemble donc l'habitude voix il
habitait dans l'ensemble
on est tout seul enfin c'est c'est une
belle famille et voilà
c'est arrivé à dormir en ce moment à
essayer d'oublier ou c'est moi j'ai ce
rôle plutôt de l'accompagnement donc on
encaisse beaucoup et on essaye d'être là
donc voilà c'est ce qu'il faut pour
l'instant la priorité c'est de tenir
nous et c'est ce que j'explique à mes
beaux-parents de tenir pour l'essayer
parceque
c'est la priorité et nous on tient pour
eux et voilà et on dormira un peu plus
tard c'est normal
vous auriez eu besoin vous d'un soutien
psychologique
ils ont parlé les quelques instants
je préfèrerais déjà qu'un soutien pour
les petites gens et ça c'est vous qui
allez faire ce ce travail en fait
patrick travail on va on va on va être
là et on va on va pas les lâcher c'est
vraiment le message à faire passer
ce soir
votre combat maintenant c'est d'essayer
que
ça se reproduise plus qui est plus comme
vous dites vous avez dit tu es quelqu'un
et se faire passer pour un fou pour ne
pas être condamné ouais c'est ce que
vous voulez on y arrive pas non ça il
faut arrêter ces des cinémas ça ça c'est
du cinéma pour moi faut arrêter sara lee
mis tout ce que disait tous les exemples
qu'elle suscite et géraldine c'est une
réalité et ça revient à ce que j'ai dit
tu essaie déjà de la fin c est fou donc
à faut arrêter de trouver des excuses là
où il y en a pas il faut condamner parce
que les victimes ont besoin de réponses
il faut parler les victimes il faut
créer un dialogue il ya des je pense
qu'il ya un système à à revoir dans ce
genre de situation d'accompagner les
victimes vraiment la gagne et de parler
avec eux aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
quand on voit ça et c'est vous avez eu
la bonne réaction que ce que vous avez
avec la police avaient appelé sur un
moment où on peut devenir fou aussi se
dire je me faire justice moi-même quand
on a ouai c'est votre conjointe
s'esquisser ouais mais il a dû se dire
c'est
parce qu'il vaut mieux ah ouais c'est ça
le problème c'est que c'est que c'est
qu'il faut qu'
il faut qu'une condamnation aussi pour
éviter justement ce genre de
débordements parce qu'après on se
retrouve de victime à coupable et c'est
injuste donc il faut que les personnes
payent pour ce qu'elles font et
quand on enlève la vie de quelqu'un il
faut il faut payer c'est normal donc
vous embrasse très fort votre compagnon
dlan vrai que je suis revenu embrasser
dans un instant qui est un garçon
formidable et j'espère que vous allez
pouvoir voilà c est ce pour s'occuper
des défis et leur redonner le sourire
moi ça va être très compliqué parce que
c'est une affaire incroyable on a tous
été très choqué par ce qui s'est passé
est tous très peinés pour vous et sachez
qu'on sera là pour vous en tout cas vous
étiez au cas où et stéphane et bien sûr
toute la famille merci en tout cas
magali si vous avez été très digne ce
soir et dans votre combat qui est
important pour ça se reproduise plus et
on espère que vous allez continuez votre
combat et que vous allez pouvoir
vraiment vous occupez d'être surtout de
la petite mélissa qui arrive demain et
qu'elle va pouvoir retrouver une vie
envie de dire une vie normale - une vie